yeah look at this wonderful human that's
here hey Ricky P Dillon either-or do you
might work what's the P stand for Porter
Porter's that you middle names yeah do
you like your middle name that's alright
it's kind of grown on me I usually hate
it but every time I tell someone my name
in like oh my god I love it I'm like oh
maybe I should like like growing up I
hated it really cuz you're like oh no
one else has this know my name exactly
that's my felt about grace growing up I
was like I want to be an Ashley or an
Amanda or something really generic and
then as I got older and people were like
that's a cool name you have I was like I
guess so
stranger thank you for your advice I
like your shirt by the way - I feel like
you have the best collection of t-shirts
oh thanks do you is that something that
you take pride in in your wardrobe no
maybe I should you just got back from
touring right I did how is that
incredible how did you guys travel did
you do a bus we had a bus super fun yeah
anyone should on the bus
I don't not that I know of versus
honestly that's the first thing I thing
about any bus tour at all well like my
big concern is like I love you know
living alone because I have my own
bathroom scenario and so plus to me is
just like crisis central for that sort
of thing on this tour not that I'm aware
of but on the old trail towards go back
two years ago we run a long ride the
middle and I couldn't stop uh-huh and
you'll say I'm pod orphan yeah yeah Sam
and Trevor both had to poop really bad
yeah so they got a bag and pooped in it
and threw it out the window oh my god
but no one knew cuz in the middle of the
night everyone knows at every show JC
what would tell the crowd about it how
can you not whatever car was behind the
bus that's what I think about
but you know what I kept thinking about
we had a couple shows some like fans
like followed the bus yeah I wonder if
like a fan got a hold of that bag and
now that's like there I'm going on eBay
right now are you a clumsy person not
typically I have my moments though what
is the worst that you've ever hurt
yourself hurt myself yeah oh do you see
this scar up here do you see that oh
yeah yeah now I do when I was five and
kindergarten this is my I guess my worst
injury um I was a door holder coming out
of recess uh-huh
and we'd had this like game where you'd
like tag the door holder at the tag you
back and it's one guy tagged me too hard
so it was a push and I hit like a what
do you mean tag the door holder and they
tag I guess you're walking you have to
like tag them and they have to tag them
back before they go in oh okay well five
come on
and I got tagged too hard so I like get
like shoved into this like block uh-huh
and it like cut you cut my head open I
got 38 stitches 30:38 was hard did he
tag you Mike really hard it was
aggressive yeah I don't remember his
name he's in jail now yeah it was 45
years old it was not a good scene that
is so you it was very graphic blood was
everywhere I did I spy I think I I'm
pretty sure I stained the halls oh my
god Wow we have 38 stitches
case you're no joke for five-year-old
your whole head hey I know that like I
can't imagine like just turned you're
seeing kids gently telling each other
than one nobody just like is it oh oh
well you've survived so are you proud of
you if the weirdest present you've ever
received
hmm I've got a lot of weird presents in
my lifetime let me think
oh I got a um this is like you know like
dirty Santa Secret Santa mm-hmm I got a
tampon one that's one tampon one son it
wasn't used okay yes I saw what could
have been worse could get worse yeah do
you believe in aliens I do and I don't
really I I think this is definitely
something out there uh-huh
like how in the world are we the only
living world sure but like if they
are real then why haven't we seen them
yet or less they're hiding like you
could be an alien that's true I say yes
you believe in aliens and I read any
alien or like ghost experiences actually
ghosts yeah really I just moved to my
new place and after my first shower
there Crais is already on I've heard so
many ghost stories recently on this
podcast and I'm like so first of all I
need a quick backstory I'm your fan of
Pretty Little Liars I've never seen how
the villains a yeah and like it would
always be like blah blah blah a that's
how they sign stuff yeah yeah okay so my
first shower there uh-huh
my mirrors fogged up and I got a shower
and there was a big a on my mirror just
just like in the show like written hey
hey so I think a ghost is with like
taunting me be like haha I know you love
this show gonna be what or maybe the
person before me wrote it there before
they left but I'd like to believe it was
her
cuz it happened again so I erased it oh
no hasn't happened since yeah yeah but
what a interesting prank to pull on
people that's like it's a ghost who's
laughing at me like they saw me watching
the show probably that night and like oh
let's just do this to him tonight that
was were you really watching the show
I'm probably was the ghost has like a
like a marketing campaign i they got
paid by the network it's spoiler alert
goes okay what's your favorite show
right now or favorite favorite spree
Liars right the flash arrow legends of
tomorrow Supernatural scandal once upon
a time Haggard murderer
Teen Wolf you daredevil Jessica Jones
hey you watch a lot yeah yeah wasn't
kidding